make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys to the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into infinity
ending and here's a funny thing I
initially plan on waiting until like
next week to start this but you guys
been screaming at me when we covered
infinity conflict to start the next part
so I was like okay I mean I don't really
see a reason not to but there's a couple
things I do want to explain here because
there was a little bit of uncertainty
that I noticed in the comments section
some of the guys seem a little unsure
and so the way this is played out so far
is we essentially had like two versions
of Thanos right we had present-day
Thanos and then we had future Thanos and
the future Thanos had somehow found a
way to essentially absorb all these
various cosmic entities right everybody
from localized and and smaller cosmic
entities like mistress death or Eternity
or infinity all the way up to like the
Living Tribunal and so initially the
question was why is he working with his
younger self and the idea was that he
was guiding present-day Thanos through a
series of steps to ensure his own
survival right to ensure that he would
become the person he became movie Oh
with regards to future Thanos and so the
result of this is that from there the
question was okay then if there's
something standing in his path then why
doesn't he stop that and this really
came into play with the death of eros in
the nature of Adam warlock
in the sense that as we talked about in
the last video Adam warlock is
essentially in world he'll always come
back right no matter how he dies and no
matter how much time passes you'll
always return this basically placed Adam
warlock outside of the norm because he
does not abide by the normal rules of
life and death
when eros was killed by Adam warlock
Adam warlock had hoped that mistress
death would banish eros from her realm
for whatever reason either because she
understood Adam warlocks goal in killing
him or because she believed that euros
was going to be working alongside Thanos
to basically use serpro role whatever
the reason was we knew that it was
because she was afraid that eros was
working alongside Thanos she banished
eros from her realm and then in turn
landed eros outside the norm because he
now no longer abides by the normal rules
of life and death he's essentially
immortal he can never really die and so
having said this what it did is it led
up to this massive battle that was
actually kind of a little bit of a
portion that that seems a little murky
here we essentially had a scenario where
Thanos had absorbed the Living Tribunal
into himself what makes this kind of
crazy is that as this comic picks up
we've got the one above all and then
you've got the Living Tribunal there
right so I don't know this is some kind
of an error or if I misinterpreted it
you know how
that happened but literally in the
preface of the book like as you open it
up and you know one of the last things
it says is like you know present-day
Thanos has killed the last embodiment
the Living Tribunal itself and merged
with his despotic future self right so
like he absorbed a living tribunal so
the question is how is the Living
Tribunal here that's really kind of how
this is now at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter because when this
happens the one above all basically
tells Thanos to stop right to stop his
actions and to in turn to go back to his
normal role and Thanos says no now the
question that a lot of people have here
and then that I noticed was a lot of
people were asking if the one above all
is this Nayan nipa tenth indestructible
an immutable force inside the entirety
of the Marvel multiverse then why
doesn't it just will Thanos out of
existence right there's nothing though
the one of them all cannot do and the
reason why is because jim Starlin is
basically altering the form and function
of the one above all and stories from
years past right old Fantastic Four
stories old sensational spider-man
stories the role of the one above all
was essentially kind of a prime mover in
the sense that like he created the first
universe we saw that in al Ewing's
Ultimates and in the first universe
basically fractured when the aspirins
and the Celestials went to war and then
those fractured pieces created the first
multiverse and by whatever manner and
whatever means those different universes
came to an end and then were reborn
again but the one above all didn't
really sit back and then like create the
first multiverse and then every time a
universe dies he creates a new one he
just sort of set things in motion and
they went through whatever path they
went through but regardless of his hands
on or lack thereof his hands on approach
with the multiverse the reality was
there's nothing that one above all
cannot do he represents the riders or
the artists or Stanley or Jack Kirby
whichever depiction you want to go with
depending on which comic you're reading
at the time jim Starlin is basically
modifying that and what he says here is
this idea that the the one above all is
actually not really a slave to the
structure of the multiverse but he can't
break its rules that the one above all
basically created all things in
existence and there are certain
safeguards there that not even the one
above all can can get past which really
kind of defies his purpose right it's
kind of like that that old-school
quagmire
can God create an object that's too
heavy for him to lift that's really what
this is right you know kind of this idea
of defying omnipotence and so that's why
it seemed a little strange because the
one above all should be able to just
will Thanos out of existence that it
should just kind of end that way but the
result is that when you're invoking
something like this you can't write you
can't on one hand
and the one above all and basically kind
of krytus an aria or Thanos faces off
against him in any believable way if
like the one above all is this immutable
and indestructible force that nothing
can stop and so what happens is over the
span of the first three pages the one
above all and then I guess the Living
Tribunal you know in this instance face
off against Thanos and Thanos
immediately absorbs them and so
essentially Thanos has now become the
new one above all and that's the crazy
thing about this right it happens like
that in the blink of an eye and it's a
wild situation because you literally
have Adam warlock and you have eros and
you have pip patrol watching this whole
thing go down and when Thanos re-emerges
Thanos is now all things in existence
from that point going forward they bail
eros grabs pip the troll he grabs Adam
warlock with the intention of
teleporting away Adam warlock Yanks his
hand away eros and pip the troll are
gone and Adam warlock remains behind and
talking to Thanos the other the new one
above all we kind of get this
explanation rather the sort of
explanation in terms of what he can do
and so on and so forth now what's also
interesting is he points out this notion
that because the fact that Adam warlock
and eros exist outside of the of the
norm that Thanos while he can detect
them has to work hard to do it right
they're not just easily perceptible to
him it's almost like it's almost like
trying to detect a dark gray amidst a
black background right it's possible you
just really have to be looking for it
and so because of that Adam warlock one
immediately picks up on that and then
too you end up having Thanos who
basically pulls out a Morlock into
himself for the purpose of always being
able to locate Adam warlock right to
kind of remove that aspect and then from
there
Thanos starts to muse and this is normal
for for jim Starlin it's actually one of
the things that always made his handling
of Thanos so cool the way he would write
the analyst was really more of he would
see himself almost kind of like in a
philosophical way right he would he
would kind of news about these things he
says now I am linked to all there is
right he's not actually I mean he is all
there is but he's linked into everything
right everything from the past and the
present throughout every single universe
that exists and it's almost overwhelming
but it's almost overwhelming for Thanos
to sit down and say all actualities all
realities that exists out there every
universe that exists in the entirety of
the multiverse I am all those things
this is a whole new level of power
that's way beyond anything that has ever
had before
the closest he ever got to this was
during Marvel the end when he absorbed
the multiverse into himself and then
brought it back with death basically
being permanent meaning nobody could be
resurrected
it was kind of a criticism of Marvel in
the sense that they always killed and
brought back people and to basically
kind of remove that or trying to make it
in continuity Marvel ultimately said no
because they like being able to kill
people and then bring them back later it
makes for good clickbait storytelling
what it does show here is really kind of
the role of the one above all in terms
of all the various forms that it exists
in and when it comes to the one above
all in Marvel it's one of these things
were like it's it's Marvel's version of
the presence from DC and the presence is
like DC's version of the one above all
right and what I mean by that is what
you have inside of the comic book
landscape you have a singular universe
then you have stuff like an over verse
or you have an under verse so on and so
forth but the fun of the the broad broad
strokes here that you have a singular
universe then you have a multiverse and
then you have what's called the
omniverse
and the way this works is that a
universe is a universe right it's just a
singular universe that you occupy the
main Marvel Universe the ultimate
universe the Marvel Cinematic Universe
those those different universes make up
the entirety of the multiverse the
omniverse is composed of all things in
existence right so there's the Marvel
multiverse in the DC multiverse and the
spawn multiverse and like like any
concept that exists out there it's part
of the greater omniverse and Marvel's
one above all it's kind of a guy who
oversees all that right as well as God
above all gods essentially so is one of
these things are they all kind of
crossover and all gets really weird and
it's not really designed to say that
like the one above all is over the
presents it's Marvel kind of saying I
mean our version is and then DC is like
no our version is and spawns like no no
you're both wrong our version is so it's
it's kind of one of these things where
just sort of goes around but Thanos is
basically tapping into you and
overseeing everything across every
single universe in every single
multiverse on every single property that
exists in the world belonging to anybody
regardless of whoever made it that's how
far-reaching this is and so it gets kind
of crazy here because with that being
the case heroes kind of picks up on the
notion of what we talked about already
that Thanos cannot easily recognize him
because he's outside the normal channels
has to hunt for him as hard as he
possibly can right a needle in a stack
of needles is really what this is and so
with that being the case because pit
patrol is essentially viewed as Thanos
as one of the people out there who can
throw a wrench in the works then what
eros does is basically tear up a
backpack more or less and then put the
troll inside of it so that pip patrol is
as close to eros as you can possibly be
and by extension of eros being out
the norm that will hopefully kind of
permeate to hit the troll now it really
kind of seems to be this idea that it's
not really like an arrow shaped hole in
the universe if that makes sense almost
kind of like a permeation of like this
energy that makes him outside the norm
that hopefully will also encompass
encompassed pip the troll that kind of
seems to be what are you shooting for
and jim Starlin plays it fast and loose
we don't really get any definitive
answers there but we're kind of more or
less left to believe that is actually
the case and so what is up happening is
is eros and pivot row basically say okay
fine then let's see what's going on
let's see if we can find a way to defeat
Thanos in the past or whatever it is
kind of throwing out these various
MacGuffins here and you end up having
arrows to pick the trolls show up on the
ship of Thanos which is currently
occupied by Corvus glaive and Proxima
midnight but then they vanish they
disappear and eros figures out this is
happening because what Thanos is doing
is getting rid of anybody who knows his
plan and who could potentially find a
way to take him out that's what's so
cool about this it's dance is just kind
of getting rid of people here in there
for this is the one thing to understand
here and this is this is awesome the way
jim Starlin does it Thanos is handling
his omnipotence and his power the way a
mortal person would Thanos is not
handling his abilities the way the one
above all would and there's a huge
distinction there and we'll find out
what that distinction is as we get
through this video but from there you
pick up with Adam warlock who basically
emerges after having been ensnared by
Thanos but Thanos his ability to see him
and essentially locates came to conquer
now again came to conquer was from a
previous infinity story but it was my
virtue of came to conquer that eros
managed to retain his time-traveling
technology as well as a few other things
going on but what this means is that
using the ability of King to manipulate
time Adam warlock seemingly has some bit
of an out and so from here we jump to
one of the most important parts of the
story when we pick up with present-day
Thanos and present-day Thanos his
consciousness is basically inside the
mind of future Thanos right like this
version of Thanos it merged with the one
above all and all that kind of stuff
that's future Thanos who's done all that
present-day Thanos is just kind of a
consciousness that's along for the ride
and it's cool when he basically talks
about this right he says things like yes
I'm so here like you know always always
basically press gained into the
situation but what it shows is that
their ideologies are not entirely linked
present-day Thanos is not fully onboard
with what future Thanos is doing but he
knows his plan he knows what he wants to
achieve but even for modern-day Thanos
that seems pretty extreme and that says
something like given whatever this
future plan
whatever this plan of future Thanos is
if present-day Thanos looks at that and
says yeah man like that's pretty crazy
man like that's pretty extreme that
means just really got to be something
right because we're talking about a guy
who got ahold of the Infinity Gauntlet
and wiped out half the life in the
universe just to impress a girl right so
like it's kind of crazy like it's kind
of not stealing in terms of this this
whole thing going but what it also shows
here and really what he what he
basically tells us is that the amount of
energy in the amount of focus necessary
to be able to handle this much power
while it's within the abilities of
future Thanos to contain these abilities
it's a whole other thing
to understand how to use them
effectively and so what this means is
that future Thanos is still figuring out
what it is that he can do he hasn't
fully been able to channel the totality
of the one above all power now this is
important because what it means is that
it presents this idea that maybe even
the one above all was limited by its own
imagination and that if Thanos can
essentially break free of those
limitations then his power would
transcend the previous one above all
power the reality of this is that what
future Thanos is doing is hunting around
for eros it's the thing that's
dominating his mind and the reason why
is because eros will in some form or
fashion find a way to basically defeat
future Thanos right like eros could find
a way to defeat his brother it's
possibly only a matter of time before
Thanos loses this power of the one above
all so again it's super cool it's a guy
with the power of God who hasn't quite
figured out how to use it all yet and so
from there you basically pick up with
eros who's like okay one he asked Isaac
the sentient computer right before it's
destroyed my future Thanos if he can
figure out a way to calculate when the
universe is going to end and they're
able to is able to basically draw you
know kind of create an algorithm you
know in the blink of an eye like super
advanced you know otherworldly computers
do and then essentially calculate when
the universe is going to end and when
eros and pit patrol are teleported there
it's just a giant empty canvas and then
future Thanos simply says let there be
an end in essence Thanos destroys
himself the idea behind this and this is
what's really important here the idea
behind this is that Thanos you know with
with these limitations that were created
by the one above all the indication is
that Thanos is still bound by those and
so what this really seems to point out
is that the future version of Thanos his
goal after having basically defeated
eros and ensuring that nobody can be in
his way is to basically wipe out
everything in existence and then
recreated as himself being the one above
all he's wiping the
clean and starting over again it removes
any of the limitations that were created
by the previous one above all and
thousands is free to recreate all the
multiverse and the omniverse as he sees
fit and that's what's so wild here it's
because what we do from America is we're
eros and pit Patrol or essentially
dispelled from that future and sit back
to the modern day what does eel because
of the fact that they cannot die right
so like they're just kick back to the
modern day what it does is it picks up
with came to conquer and Adam warlock
having a discussion with each other and
Cain the Conqueror not really wanting to
you essentially admits that what you
know the the kind of field that he's on
right now with Thanos attaining the
power of the one above all with the
actions of Adam warlock things like that
these are way beyond what king is
normally used to and the reality is he's
basically being reduced to a guy who
could just help Adam warlock out as best
he can despite all the intelligence and
all the time-traveling abilities of Cain
he's way out of his element here more so
than that Adam warlock throws in this
idea and really kind of gives us some
this amazing notion that future Thanos
operating with all this power again who
has not figured out how to use it and in
the time that he could be taking to
figure out how to use it instead he's
taking that time to focus on finding
eros this makes him vulnerable this is
basically just a really really really
powerful Thanos and that's why we don't
really have an instance where it's like
well why did you just go back to the
very beginnings of time and stop eros
from being born if Thanos went back in
time and killed eros at birth then
perhaps future Thanos never exists it is
really kind of bound by the rules of
time play the rules of time travel time
manipulation different things like that
and so what we end up doing is picking
up with Adam warlock right Adam warlock
basically trying to find a particular
access point within the cosmos basically
an access point what that will allow him
to enter the psyche of future Thanos
right because he's undetectable or at
least it seemed to be that way and then
like entering the future psyche if
Thanos and then in turn you know just
kind of getting a better understanding
of what's going on now the reason why
Adam warlock is able to do this is not
because he's undetectable that's my
mistake he is but the reason why Adam
warlock can do this is because Adam
warlock is part and partial to Thanos
and so Thanos won't really feel it is
like an ant biting him or anything like
that he'll just kind of see it as the
normal comings and goings of the
multiverse and how things function and
so on and so forth and because his
attention is off of Adam warlock because
he believes that Adam warlock is now a
negated factor right he's not in
anything to really worry about instead
he with him focusing on eros
it leaves
Morlock open to invade the psyche of
Thanos because he's just not paying
attention but before Adam warlock can do
that he suddenly met by the arrival of
an unexpected character okay so we are
picking back up again with the Infinity
ending and we're actually we're ending
the Infinity ending
I thought about titling that infinity in
being ending it seemed kind of weird but
in the last video we eventually left off
with the idea that Adam warlock was
essentially met out of nowhere
by a person that I kind of left you guys
on a cliffhanger on and the reality is
it's not actually a person but a group
of people it's pretty much all the
versions of Adam warlock from the past
and the funny thing about this is this
goes all the way back to him like the
guy who's not wearing anything but
underwear that's how Adam warlock first
appeared when he was in Marvel Comics
and there's just different iterations of
his character as time has gone on and
the funny thing about this is that Adam
warlock has historically been a guy
where his understanding of the the
cosmos and the multiverse has kind of
been really beyond most other people
even the cosmic entities themselves
right it's the reason why Thanos wanted
him to become the New Living Tribunal
when we were reading one of the older
infinity stories but when you when you
get into this what you end up having is
the scenario where these versions of
Adam really kind of say no like
self-preservation is more important than
the universe and there's a couple of
reasons why they're coming from this
perspective the first is because they're
sentient beings right it's just the
nature of us as people we care about
ourselves more than we care about other
things right it's just the way that we
are and so what we also have here is the
notion that Adam warlock can never truly
die and so a matter no matter what
happens in this universe where it ends
or where it returns Adam warlock will
essentially always end up returning and
as other selves sort of recognize this
right but the idea of Adam warlock and
this really kind of seems to be an
ideology force character that's changed
over the years but the ideology of Adam
Adam warlock at this point in time is
saving the universe is the most
important thing and in reality it's not
as though they're killing off an entire
universe of people it's quite the
opposite defeat one guy in order to save
all of creation right is classic
utilitarianism the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few and so is
a cool perception here's a cool notion
here because Adam warlock has been
without his soul Jim for quite some time
now the reality is kind of warlock
doesn't really need the soul Jim I mean
it kind of helps to bolster his power a
bit but he never really needed it I mean
he was exceedingly powerful even without
the Jim but what he ins up doing with
these various guys he's various versions
of themselves is basically snatching the
soul Jim off of one of their
heads and then essentially overpowering
all the others now we don't really know
exactly what happens to them but
regardless of the situation the result
is that Adam warlock ends up coming out
on top and so following this he
basically dives to a portal and into the
consciousness of Thanos now this is not
the first time this has happened they've
been inside each other's minds before in
the subconscious mind of Adam warlock
it's all about death and rebirth right
people riding an elevator all the way up
to the top of this cliff more or less
falling off dying and then getting back
up and doing it all over again this
cycle of death and rebirth constantly
taking place with Thanos it was just
nihilism reign supreme right just just
death and destruction and so Adam kind
of dives into the mind of the one above
all Thanos that we're talking about now
and the funny thing about this is that
each one of these places that he sees is
now an entire universe unto itself Adam
warlock is hopping from one universe to
the next within the mind of one above
all Pharaohs but that's more or less
what's going on here one of the first
memories he sees or one of the first
things he sees is Stannis
as a little kid who basically breaks so
a lamp now the funny thing about this is
we can look at this a couple different
ways right we can look at this story as
being out of continuity or we can look
at the story being in continuity and the
reason why is because suisse ons
currently there so those are the guys
who read the rise and fall of Tanis I
think it was I think it was Ed Brubaker
or Jason Aaron one of those two who
wrote it we basically got the life and
times of Thanos right all the events
that led to him in encountering mistress
death for the very first time and then
going forward and becoming the villain
that we that we all know and love in the
early days sweets on land when I say
early days I mean like almost
immediately after giving birth mr ihsan
tried to kill thanos because she saw him
as a bad omen and had a vision that his
actions would lead to the downfall and
the destructions of everybody on titan
which it did and so she tried to take
him out and ultimately she was thrown in
a mental institution and so if this
story is in continuity at the time that
Thanos is this age suisse on should be
in a mental institution but she's not
she's there so that kind of leads us to
believe that either it was jim Starlin
kind of trying to correct things and
saying no no this is how it should be or
it's not in continuity but the other
funny thing that kind of comes out of
this is eros and pip the troll now
remember these are two guys and while
they're not necessarily bumbling
buffoons they certainly don't have any
real kind of concrete plan like their
plan here to try to stop future Thanos
from acquiring all this insane power
capturing his modern-day self and then
going on to become the one above all
their whole attempt to basically stop
that is to convince Thanos that he's a
good guy that he's cool you know and
that like eros loves him and that's
basically it
right
like words don't win conflicts more or
less and so because of that we end up
kind of jumping through these different
moments in fan OSes life and you kind of
have Danice when he's relatively young
when he's you know kind of going through
that that age of bodies changing in
puberty and he's kind of put on a few
pounds you know and drinking a soda it
looks like and eros tries to convince
Stannis it's like he's a cool guy
you know the Thanos is great that Aris
loves him and it is really yours like
trying to convince Thanos of this right
the next time they appear is when Thanos
is feeding some bullies to some monsters
in a cave because the bullies needed to
understand their place in the bigger
picture following that like it's battles
basically launching an attack and
destroy the entire planet our planet of
Titan all these different things that
are going on with Thanos committing
these acts and as this is going on we
have two versions of Thanos here that's
one thing to keep in mind we've got
essentially what amounts to present-day
Thanos were the easiest way to think
about it and then we've got future
Thanos and if you guys recall in the
last video we talked about this right
future Thanos was the one that was
trying to attain the power to become the
one above all present-day Thanos is the
one who is being used in order to follow
in those footsteps and assure that that
path was actually followed and one
present-day Thanos went through all
those steps then he was absorbed by
future Thanos to ensure that nothing
would ever go wrong and that's why you
see this version of Thanos is sort of
hovering in a tank this is present-day
Thanos being held prisoner by his future
self and so eros and then basically
arriving to what's actually Thanos his
first appearance in Marvel Comics when
he fought Iron Man in terms of his a
chronological appearances we have them
showing up in instances like during the
events of Infinity Gauntlet these really
cool little moments here and there and
it's one of these things where
present-day Thanos kind of says okay
like I can reach you out basically
psychically and I can communicate with
them but I can talk to them through my
past self basically and that's what you
see playing out here right like eros and
his guys will show up to a particular
point in time and then Thanos will talk
to them and as they basically kind of
went over their plan but they only get
brief moments right they only get these
really really small moments and the
reason why this is kind of being held
off the reason why these moments are
only ever so short is because
present-day Thanos realizes that if they
stop and they talk for too long it'll
create abnormalities in the timestream
that his future version will become
aware of and then start tracing them
down and ultimately realizing what it is
an eros and pip Patrol are trying to do
and at the end of the day again
it doesn't really matter they're not
actually doing anything oh but it is
kind of a cool little effort right it is
a cool attempt one of the other funny
things to come out of this is that
because of all these paradoxes and
and all these shifts that IRA's and hip
Patrol are making they end up showing up
at a future point in time and we have
the cosmic entities but they're
different this right here actually
doesn't really make any sense and the
reason why is if you understand the
nature of cosmic entities they exist in
two forms right they exist in their true
form which is an abstract form it has no
true physical form right they're just an
ideology if you had like the desire to
go get something to eat it would be like
if that desire to eat could get up and
walk around right that thought that
concept could get up and move that's
what a cosmic entity is now when cosmic
entities appear in a physical form they
go to the dimension and manifestations
and they basically receive a form from
anthropomorphic
and then they show up in the main Marvel
Universe in a physical form but it's
just what are these these these small
little things right so you know it's
it's a it's a cool little moment it's a
little a little wonky and a little crazy
but again that's kind of what we're
dealing with here are sort of these
escapades of jumping back and forth
through time and so when eros is talking
to present-day Thanos when they say like
like I guess we can work together and
eros is very much unsure about this
because it's trusting a guy who's well
known for betrayal Thanos is kind of
like at the end of the day our goals are
basically mutual here at the end of the
day like we're trying to achieve the
same goal
I'm currently trapped in the essence
more or less of my future self come
there rescue me and then like we'll save
the day and the cool thing about that is
that when that happens when arrow shows
up it's not really heroes saving Thanos
instead eros is seemingly kind of
whisked away
eros just sort of says like this isn't
right this isn't how it's supposed to be
and he just ends up taking off and a
warlock pizzas head in to see what eros
is doing while he's on his journey and
then basically you know once once that
happens Adam warlock kind of pops back
in or at least sort of disappears for a
second when future Thanos shows up and
the reason why this matters is because
future Thanos as we know was looking for
eros not to kill him or to capture him
but because with eros existing outside
of life and death then it was basically
impossible for one above all Thanos to
track him down now again this is jim
Starlin shifting things around this is
jim Starlin changing things under normal
circumstances and everything up to this
point it's not how the one above all
work everything that is is the one above
all the face that you see when it speaks
to things is no different than eternity
popping up and then like talking to
somebody right it's just the entirety of
the omniverse on all things coalescing
in the form of a face that can have a
conversation with you with that being
the case anything even if it's outside
the realm of life and death is still
part of the one above all if
exist if it talks if it's if it's
anything that can be drawn or written it
exists as part of the one above also
again Jim Starla is kind of shifting
things up and saying that's not
necessarily the case here right like you
know anything that exists outside of
life and death meaning it can't truly
die it's outside the one above all's
purview because it's considered an
anomaly right which is kind of crazy to
sort of limit the power of the one above
all and a lot of the guys are making
comments about that you were saying like
well I guess now he's just the one above
most is what it is and you're not wrong
right you're not entirely wrong the one
above pretty much most things unless the
plot calls for him to not be above
things like that's basically what it is
you know and so it's it's kind of wild
here but with IRA's having popped up and
basically shown up in the essence of
future Thanos to rescue present-day
Thanos by default he made himself part
of future Thanos therefore everything is
now complete by future Thanos has
attained his goal of tracking down eros
basically making eros a part of himself
even if it was only because eros just
sort of walked into it right so it's
essentially Thanos was trying to get us
into a house and eros just sort of
wandered in there on his own that's
really kind of what this is right now
when future Thanos basically leaves Adam
warlock then pops up and that's when
present-day Thanos is like you have to
free me from this prison where the the
responsive Adam warlock is no I'm not
going to do that you have to trust me
here you need to stay here this is all
part of my plan now Thanos initially
sort of questions it and isn't really
sure but the reality is that Adam
warlock is kind of a master planner as
one of these things where when Adam
warlock comes up with a plan it's not
really to be questioned the issue it is
is we're talking about uncharted
territory it's one thing to create a
plan just half Thanos lose the Infinity
Gauntlet
because you get too carried away with
himself and because warlock understands
Fanus the subconscious mind and how he
thinks it's another to form a plan
against a seemingly nyama 'putin being
that cannot truly be destroyed by
anybody here or really anything in
existence right so you know like I have
a plan to defeat a being that cannot be
defeated that's kind of what that what
that sort of comes down to you and it's
a little wild there because what Adam
warlock ends up doing is basically
watching all of this go down right the
idea was okay let's let this play out
and let's see what happens it's a
dangerous gambit because this could fail
in in the most spectacular sense but
future Thanos ends up doing what he
intended to do he ends up wiping away
all of reality now we didn't know what
the motivation was before but we
currently do now and the idea is that
future Thanos looks around and
almost kind of agreeable in terms of
what it is that he's doing and why he's
doing it right at the end of the day he
kind of makes his argument between
utilitarianism and deontology chol
ethics the intentions versus actions
let's say for example that like you see
a homeless man and you give that
homeless man 5 bucks well your idea is
to just give that guy 5 bucks to help
him along his way but what if in reality
by giving him that $5 all you've done is
make him a target for somebody else
because he didn't earn that $5 he
doesn't know how to keep it and because
you don't know how to keep it either he
swindled by somebody who dupes him out
of it or he's not physically capable of
holding it on his own
somebody beats him up and then takes it
would he have died had you not given him
that $5 that's the the philosophical
quandary that we're talking about here
and depending on what philosophical
viewpoint you come from whether you're a
fault or not begins to shift if we say
the only thing that matters is intention
right that's the only thing that really
matters here is intention then at the
end of the day it's like then your
intention was to make that guy's life
better and that's where your
responsibility stops right that's where
it ends as far as you're concerned you
did what you thought was a good thing
done right we're finished there from
there then it starts going into things
like okay if all that matters is action
then you gave that guy five dollars but
then you also cost him his life and so
is your act more well you know that's
that's the kind of issue that you run
into here and so it's one of these
things where Thanos really kind of looks
at it and says the only thing that
really matters in this universe matters
in this world is actions right what
people's intentions are don't matter
what matters are deeds
and that everything is just a giant
contest right even the cosmic entities
seek to be supreme over the other in
some form or fashion despite the fact
that they're designed to be immutable
the despite the fact of their design to
be these forces that that represent
ideas and they don't really seek to
better one another at the end of the day
there's still a kind of contest there
and so Thanos his responses then will
recreate things loyalty was conceived to
deceive people
Trust is a fantasy for fools and is
basically played upon by scoundrels who
look to exploit the universe as it
exists now is one of naivety is people
who believe they can change the universe
and so on by just doing good things
you're believing good things but at the
end of the day like it's a screwed up
and terrible place this seems to be like
the core perspective of Thanos and so
with that being the case II says okay
then let's recreate everything and so
with that going down let you know
without happy in the way that it does
you know he basically goes to
essentially recreate all of existence
and it offers this momentary gambit
right
you have Adam warlock who's essentially
outside the existing multiverse washing
it all began right once he retreats
outside of Thanos and kind of goes back
to this outside the multiverse kind of
space that in turn like once future
Thanos wipes everything out of existence
and then seems to recreate everything we
kind of get this brief moment where
present-day Thanos Finchley says okay
now's a chance to actually do something
I get this brief moment to basically
take this action and then basically Adam
warlock just kind of wakes up in the
void without any real indication of
where he is or where he's at he's just
kind of out in this total oblivion of
absolute nothingness and the indication
is that he's totally outside of all
recreated existence the omniverse as it
exists he's way out there to give you
perspective this is more or less just
stories that have not been told yet and
so with him being out there out in the
void out in the nothingness there's no
stars no planets no nothing just
infinite blackness but he ends up
getting this kind of life line that
comes through a sort of portal where
he's basically yanked forward by Kang
the Conqueror and that was the idea was
to really have Kang basically grab eros
and pip Patrol to ensure they stayed
alive Adam warlock didn't quite know
what would happen to him but the more
important thing was to ensure that
everything was safe and the plan
basically went as he expected that in
this moment of vulnerability in this
moment where future Thanos had basically
dispersed his energy or attempted to
disperses energy present-day Thanos
basically seized that power for himself
but after seizing all that power of the
one above all from his future
counterpart because of the fact that
present-day Thanos never really agreed
with his future counterpart his future
version ceased to exist just by virtue
of destroying his essence more or less
and then present-day Thanos use the
power of the one above all to reset
everything back to normal and this is
where the story totally falls short and
the reason why is because we don't see
any of that happen it's all explained to
Adam warlock by Kang the Conqueror who
watched it all go down
right so Adam warlock wasn't even really
a part of it he wasn't a part of seeing
everything recreated and all that kind
of stuff
some will probably say well we didn't
need to see that others will say
something something something jim
Starlin higher plane of reasoning who
knows but whatever the case is it's
basically one of these things were like
we missed out on what could have been a
really really cool appearance of a story
or some exposition and some explanation
there in terms of like why Thanos did
what he did in terms of like from his
perspective because we know why he did
what he did and we get the exposition
it's just from some time-traveling guy
that makes stories overly complicated
and so it's like okay that's kind of
weird and so they kind of make a final
stop it Adam
warlock of course again still in
possession of the soul stone presents
the the reality stone to Thanos and the
truth and this is kind of the important
thing here the truth is that it's
entirely possible that his future self
could get carried away with power again
and the entire process could repeat
itself but it's one of these things were
Adam warlock truss Thanos right he
trusts the character of Thanos to do
what needs to be done not only that it
basically we kind of have this this sort
of assumption that we have to make that
if present-day Thanos did take the power
of the one above all from his future
counterpart and then set everything back
that he may have just kind of walked to
the timestream just find out exactly
what went wrong or where he kind of
lived through the timestream so he knows
the mistakes that he made and we kind of
have to assume that like if he did set
everything back he's aware of of himself
he's aware of like what he would've what
he would become or something like that
it's not clearly explained it's not
clearly defined and I think that's kind
of one of the issues here but it sort of
leaves things pretty ambiguous right and
it really feels like the ending in his
story was wrapped up super fast right he
was just wrapped up very very quickly
and it sort of left a bit to be desired
but at the end of the day things just
kind of go back to the way they were
before but everything that sort of goes
back to normal and then you kind of have
Adam warlock who's just sort of sitting
there in a bar you know out in it were
really in stallyns bars when they call
it Jim someone named to borrow after
himself but he's just kind of sitting in
a bar and just sort of chilling there
and people kind of have this concern
that things are not necessarily going
back for the better but at the end of
the day we won't truly know as far as
I'm aware this is the last of the
infinity stories that jim Starlin is
right of course I think infinity finale
was also supposed to be the last one and
that it wasn't but at the end of the day
this is really we're just kind of wraps
up so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explain and
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]